in one of the oldest neighborhoods of
Istanbul by the Bosphorus people are
preparing to elect their leaders for the
first time in more than 20 years
president
faces a United opposition of six parties
from right to left
the race between him and his opponent
opposition leader Kamal khalidarolu is
too close to call
it's not the thieves but the realists
that will Triumph kalist forever some
accuse erdogan of taking the country
towards authoritarianism and undermining
its founding secular principles a
struggling economy runaway inflation and
the collapsing currency have caused
Financial issues for millions of Turks
many people are struggling to pay for
food and cover their rent these days and
February's powerful earthquakes just
three months before the election caused
an estimated 100 billion dollars in
Damages and killed more than 50 000
people
I will vote based on bread sweat usurp
rights and Injustice a society crumbles
if you intervene Injustice at every step
you cannot lead the great Turkish
Republic to destruction I don't care
whether you build a bridge or a highway
it's already your responsibility but it
wasn't always this way between 2002 and
2021 the Turkish annual Judy Peak Roth
averaged 5.8 percent setting a
distinguished example among fellow
developing countries while the present
supporters say he's done a lot to keep
the country strong and independent
for the Homeland the prayer called the
flag our country and our survival it is
erdogan I would die for this flag and
this land
people are polarized
often with no hesitation for horse talk
but there is room for small alliances of
marginal parties and candidates who want
to attract young voters who have grown
up with only one governing party
star district and just days before it is
most political election both suggest
president erdon and his main opponents
opinion policy are not always reliable
but the possibility of present Arizona
losing the election on May 14 is no
longer Unthinkable but he still has high
levels of support especially among
religious and more conservative voters
no candidates secures an outright
majority then a second one will be held
later this month CNM casulo Al jazire
Istanbul